so I think the very question itself
makes an assumption it assumes that
space and time and physical objects are
fundamental that that the fundamental
reality of space and time and particles
and Quantum Fields is not conscious
and that somehow Consciousness is a
latecomer in the universe that somehow
life emerged from un
non-organic starting points uh you know
like particles and then eventually
Consciousness emerged and I think that
the whole framework is is wrong that our
best science Quantum field Theory with
Einstein theory of gravity and evolution
of a natural selection tell us that
space and time are not fundamental the
elementary particles are not the
fundamental reality and so the whole
framework of the question how does
Consciousness arise from physical
systems neurons or artificial
intelligence is is the wrong way to
frame the question because space and
time themselves are not fundamental so
we have to to to come up with a more
fundamental framework to even address
this question what is beyond space and
time and physicists are finding new
structures like decorative permutations
beyond space and time so they're going
to change completely how we even think
about this question so so my answer is
that we're not thinking deeply enough
about the question if we frame it that
way Susan
so I guess here I would say no first and
foremost
um I call my approach to machine
Consciousness the wait and see approach
um it's designed to be a middle ground
between a view called biological
naturalism which says Consciousness is
intrinsically biological and a view
called techno optimism associated with
thinkers like Ray Kurzweil and other
transhumanists that view claims that
conscious machines are inevitable as an
outgrowth of sophisticated intelligence
I reject both of these views
um first off let me say
Consciousness in machines the idea is
conceptually and logically coherent we
see it in science fiction films all the
time there's nothing logically flawed
about the idea my problem though is with
the idea that the Techno optimists have
that as AI gets smarter and smarter
Consciousness will be an outgrowth of
intelligent machines so I think that um
we don't know if building conscious AI
is compatible with the laws of nature we
don't know if it's technically feasible
even if it is compatible with the loss
of nature to actually build conscious
machines and we don't know if AI
companies would even want to do it I
mean look at the mess with lake lemoy
right
um he claimed that Google's Lambda
system was conscious
and it got him in a lot of trouble
um Google's Lambda system claimed to be
conscious
these large language models they're
getting smarter and smarter if they look
to the public like they're conscious I
bet Google and the rest of big Tech will
try not to build conscious AI because if
you're trying to build an AI service
and people are convinced it's conscious
that looks like slavery
Bernardo I'm with uh Dawn that
Consciousness is not something that is
generated it's not a secondary or
epiphenomenon of nature it is primary it
is out there but when we ask is a
computer conscious we mean something
else we we mean to say that the computer
has a private conscious inner life of
its own and I do think private conscious
in our life arises it emerges in nature
it's not something that was there from
the get-go so the question now is okay
we know that we biological entities have
private conscious in their lives does a
computer or can a computer ever have
private conscious in their life I would
say we have absolutely no good reason to
think that at all certainly not idealism
idealism would say everything is in
Consciousness not that everything is
conscious in the sense of having private
conscious in their life of its own the
justification for the hypothesis that
silicon computers will be conscious is
based on some form of isomorphism more
concrete reality of a silicon computer
and a brain a metabolizing wet brain and
and and realize that they are completely
different and that's to find the
similarity you have to take several
steps of abstraction away from concrete
reality until you find a level where
there is an isomorphism but it's
entirely arbitrary to say that at that
level the similarity is defining and
that all preceding levels don't matter
although they show profound
dissimilarities that those don't matter
to me this is a form of belief I think
the chance that a silicon computer will
be conscious is just about the same as
the chance that my computer will pee on
my desk if I run an accurate simulation
of kidney function on it now when it
comes to urine we understand the
difference between a phenomenon and the
simulation of the phenomenon but when it
comes to Consciousness for some reason
we don't and I think the reason for that
is that the the human impulse for
religion manifests itself in whatever
way it can and transhumanism is a is an
expression of the religious impulse and
it abandons reason abandons evidence and
engages into a very suspicious uh form
of thinking that is more about Wishful
belief than than reason all right let's
penetrate to the core of this dispute
what is consciousness and what best
explains Consciousness we'll go in order
of Bernardo Susan and Don and Bernardo
briefly if you don't mind explaining to
the person or thing being simulated in
the machine does it not feel wetness the
wetness is not outside the machine but
to what's being simulated if you could
integrate that into your answer so when
I use the word Consciousness I mean
phenomenal Consciousness an entity is
conscious if there is something it is
like to be that entity in other words if
the entity has experience at the most
basic level so for me Consciousness does
not require higher levelment of
functions such as metacognition
self-reflection introspection no if
there is some things like to be
something then that something is
conscious is there something it is like
to be an entity in a computer their
stimulation no I don't think there is
anything it is like to be that entity in
the same sense that there is nothing
it's like to be my computer mouse
actually there isn't even a mouse
because you know not everything we have
a name for in language is an actual
entity in this the ontological structure
of nature so I think the the burden of
argument is on those who think computers
will be conscious because I don't think
we have any reason uh to entertain the
hypothesis seriously at all I I can't
refuse to the hypothesis but then again
I can't refute the Flying Spaghetti
Monster the burden is not on me to
refute the Flying Spaghetti Monster
people have to provide an argument for
us to take that hypothesis seriously I
think conscious silicon computers are
the same thing and they are not better
epistemically at all it's just the same
kind of
well if if I'm if I'm maybe myself the
same kind of nonsensical hypothesis
Susan
please answer the question but also if
you want to respond to any of the
comments Bernardo I just made I agree
with Bernardo that it's this
quality of experience
from the inside to be that entity and
the big question is whether a machine
could be conscious
um maybe I'll just address the issue
from my perspective as the former leader
of a big project at Nasa and the NASA
chair
because there my job was to articulate
the relationship between Consciousness
and intelligence and talk about how we
might locate either one in the universe
and one thing I want to caution against
actually and I know all of us here we
have very detailed metaphysical theories
of Consciousness is assuming
from our theories that we can read in to
the search for conscious machines or
conscious beings on other planets
because look at the search for life in
the context of astrobiology
when you look at the definition of life
that NASA endorses for example
self-replicating and capable of
biological evolution
it is tremendously open capable of
darwinian evolution in particular to the
possibility that life could look very
different on other planets it doesn't
need to be
recognizably life to us the big thing
that I think we need to do here when we
search for other forms of Consciousness
is keep an open mind and realize that
it's going to look very different than
the human case and I think the
interesting question here from a
theoretical standpoint is how different
will allow it to be before we say it's
not Consciousness at all which is one
thing I want to throw out there so
Bernardo and I both thought well
Consciousness is essentially the
phenomenal feel well to me that does
seem like a necessary ingredient
in Consciousness and if a machine lacks
it then to me it doesn't
seem conscious it has some other
qualities and maybe based on those
it will be dangerous or it will be of
moral significance but I think that
that is one thing where
if we were to look for Consciousness
elsewhere
we might take as a fundamental
ingredient but I think it will be very
very different
when we get to the case of synthetic
machines briefly you said it was
necessary the felt experience of
Consciousness is it also sufficient
if that's too long of an answer then
we'll get to dance
find that felt quality I mean for
example there are some people who define
consciousness in such a demanding way
like Daniel Dennett in his paper quinine
qualia uh you know where he listed like
seven fundamental ingredients or other
people try to build in a whole Theory
like a higher order Theory Of
Consciousness that intellectualizes
consciousness
and that's where I think we need to be
incredibly open and humble and not
import our own theories of consciousness
into the debate too early okay done
you know I would agree that
Consciousness is something that's
experienced something phenomenal so for
example my uh the taste of coffee the
smell of a rose uh the feeling of a
headache these are all specific
conscious experiences and so that's what
I'm what I mean when I talked about
conscious experiences and what's
remarkable is that
my my brilliant friends and colleagues
who are are studying this problem using
cognitive neuroscience and or physical
systems like artificial intelligences
uh theories like the integrated
information Theory or orchestrated
collapse of quantum States and micropubu
bills and so forth what's remarkable is
that um when you look at all these
theories there is not a single specific
conscious experience
that has ever been explained what is the
pattern of integrated information that
must be the taste of vanilla and could
not possibly be the smell of a rose what
is the orchestrated collapse the precise
orchestrated collapse of quantum States
and microtubules that must be the taste
of chocolate and could not be you know
the taste of garlic
these are my friends I've asked them in
public that copperases and so forth give
me a specific conscious experience that
you that your theory can tell us because
these are supposed to be theories of
conscious experience so they should
explain conscious experiences so what
experience can you explain what
integrated information must be the taste
of chocolate or or whatever one you you
can do and what's remarkable is there is
no physicalist Theory
or integrated information Theory or work
straight class whatever there is no
theory of that type that can explain
even one specific conscious experience
we're batting zero nothing there's
nothing on the table so so so that's why
I said it's premature to talk about so
how could computers boot up
Consciousness we we have no idea about
how anything could boot up Consciousness
right now from a physical system
literally nothing is on the table so so
until we can solve that we don't know
how neurons could possibly boot up
Consciousness there's nothing on the
table so that's why this is a you know I
said it was premature to be asking
whether
um you know only biological systems can
boot up Consciousness not AIS we have no
theory about how biological systems can
boot up conscience there's there's
literally nothing on the table that
makes sense and I predict that there
that's a principled problem this is not
simply these are bright people these are
good friends of mine they're they're
brilliant but when you start with space
and time and physical objects inside
space and time like particles or neurons
or whatever
um you're starting with what physics
tells us is not fundamental reality so
if you're starting with something that
we know is not fundamental good luck
trying to boot up a theory of anything
else from that so so that's my sort of
my diagnosis of the problem so we have
to go after
I think I agree with with Bernardo you
know starting with an idea in which
Consciousness itself is fundamental and
Bernard was going after that
philosophically as a scientist I'm
trying to go after it mathematically try
to get a mathematically precise theory
of the very kinds of things that that
Bernard was talking about and then show
how space and time
are booted up precisely from a theory of
Consciousness so get a dynamics of
Consciousness outside of space-time and
boot up space and time and and for
example
um scattering amplitudes of particles
get all of that
um without a hand wave get all of that
derived precisely from a theory of
Consciousness so in other words we've
tried to start with space and time and
particles and biology and tried to boot
up a theory of Consciousness from that
we've not gotten a single success not
one specific conscious experience but if
we start with Consciousness being
fundamental and the mathematical model
of that then I think we can boot up
space and time and particles and show
where they come up and and we can bat
100 on that so I think we should start
with Consciousness and show space and
time is just a user interface that some
Consciousness is used but if we start
the other direction our best science
tells us good luck you've got the wrong
Foundation you just watched a clip from
the theories of everything channel for
the full video and all its magnificence
then click here and if you'd like to see
more then subscribe enjoy